the Supreme Court has blocked Joe
Biden's student loan debt relief this is
listen
one of the things I always say is we
have to deal with things as they are not
as we would rather them be the reality
is that because Donald Trump defeated
Hillary Clinton in 2016 and blame
whatever you want for that or whoever
you want because Trump got to pick
people for the Supreme Court
this among many other decisions are
things we now have to deal with Roe v
Wade overturned Etc do I think that we
need student loan debt relief I do
am I surprised that this is the way the
Supreme Court decided I am not and so
this should be a reminder about the
importance of not letting Trump or
DeSantis or whoever get potential
Supreme Court picks starting in January
of 2025 it should remind us we have to
vote in November of 2024.